les votes c'est nicolas quarks ans je ne
payerai pas une chose à moi dans le
monde du tuning
le tout automobile c'est une expression
de personnes vesti je veux retourner
chez mes parents je la vole 350 des
rassemblements de jeunes comme celui ci
ont lieu quotidiennement dans des
stationnements en banlieue nous avons
passé une partie de la nuit dans ce
stationnement de place sainte eustache
dans le langage du milieu il s'agit d'un
mythe est pas ici s'ils sont vraiment
comme il nous laisse aller tant qu'on
sera mars contient les lieux propres
fait pas de bruit
y a pas de grosse musique fait qu'on
dérange pour personne avec ses succès
plus propice 1 que les gens viennent ici
il ya du monde qu'il n'a pas marqué les
services arrivent dans une passion pour
les voitures mais aussi un lieu où
passer le temps parce que qu'on a
vraiment besoin de se défouler de sa
musique si c'est le combo drive c'est là
qu'on va se défouler qu'on va s'amuser
ici le seul endroit tranquille en jasant
s'amuser entre amis c'est l'esthétique
du véhicule est une priorité
à quelques minutes de là d'autres
poussent leur machine à fond sur la
piste de l'autodrome saint-eustache
une initiative qui a pour but d'éviter
que les jeunes course dans les rues
break de rue légal sur une piste de
course encadrée
donc vraiment le tout les éléments de
sécurité et en dehors de la piste
il se passe rien tu verras jamais dans
ces soirées là quelqu'un faire quand le
cas écrit et plus ou faire ce qu'on
appelle un bon vieux chaude du cam en
dehors de la piste
j'aimais le monde dont le respect
vraiment et non voter quand même assez
bruyant on sait que ça flirte avec lui
c'est clair la musique et la musique
aussi sa flotte avec les cap vers la
voiture monte comment on fait pour
respecter les règles
enfin la date la ligne est mince des
fois mais c'est surtout c'est de servir
de sa taille est à la base parce que
modifier une voiture si on le fait bien
sûr le fait dans les règles de l'art on
interfèrent pas que la sécurité au
contraire souvent on va améliorer la
tenue de route on va améliorer freinage
alors leur dire que ça rend le tout
dangereux ce serait pas vrai
un autre facteur de succès en banlieue
des événements reconnu
internationalement s'y déroulent dans
cette compétition de dérapage contrôlé
au moment de notre passage dix mille
personnes étaient réunies pour vibrer au
rythme de leur passion mais parfois le
désir d'imiter leurs idoles sur la route
dérange on est dans le stationnement du
restaurant partage 2000 à la balle à
proximité de l'autoroute 40
aujourd'hui c'est assez calme mais vous
allez voir qu'en soirée c'est assez
différent
où
ce rassemblement est organisé tous les
lundis il serait le plus gros québec
parfois près de 100 voitures s'y
retrouve
mais cet été des dizaines de plaintes
ont été déposées à la police pour bruit
et vitesse dans le secteur
on l'a eu des plaintes qui ont commencé
à être acheminée la centrale 9 1 en juin
et puis suite à cela nos policiers sont
venus ont fait une intervention
et puis on détecte un phénomène donc on
a mis des policiers en charge de
s'assurer que la sécurité routière aux
abords du phénomène soit optimale pour
éviter que des gens qu'ils soient
blessés
la police de laval le reconnaît elle
tolère les rassemblements mais si
dérapage il ya elle n'hésite pas à
intervenir
c'est à dire elle a même réalisé une
vidéo pour informer les passionnés des
modifications permise sur les véhicules
même si certains ne respectent pas les
règles
reste que d'autres dénoncent les
préjugés à leur endroit
votre télé on fait ce qu'on aime qui
sont au bout puis on essaye enfants de
le faire un respectable ce qu'on peut
jérémy à 21 ans il habite sur la rive
sud de montréal
il travaille comme peintre en
carrosserie et se définit comme un
artiste dans le milieu il a investi 40
mille dollars dans sa voiture en
respectant le code de la route il se
fait fréquemment intercepté par les
policiers notamment l'essence dans une
station service puis la police à
l'attendaient derrière la voiture sans
même avoir entendu un bruit l'avoir vu
je n'ai rien fait de mal en fait
défection vers la travée que je parte
pas pour me coller là c'est un peu plate
âgé mais des ponts des faits qu'on soit
génocide
quoi qu'il en soit la police et les
passionnés cherchent un terrain
d'entente afin que cette activité puisse
continuer d'exister mais en toute
sécurité
ici marielle tremblay radio-canada grand
montréal